[THEME MUSIC]
SPEAKER: All right,
well, everybody,
we are so fortunate today to
have Chef Mark Djozlija with us
from Wright & Co.
So if you could
please-- let's give him
a huge round of
applause and welcome him
to Google here in Birmingham.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHING]
MARC DJOZLIJA: Thank
you, that's very kind.
I was actually surprised
at all the pictures of me
on the walls.
It was kind of funny.
But--
SPEAKER: Did you know you'd--
MARC DJOZLIJA: [INAUDIBLE]
what's going on here?
Yes, but no, it's great.
SPEAKER: Did you know we
needed a signed, autographed
photograph of you, too?
MARC DJOZLIJA: I
signed one, as well.
So yeah, I'm very
honored and humbled
to be here in the first place.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So thank you.
Thanks for inviting me.
I appreciate it.
SPEAKER: Yes, thank you so
much, Marc, for being here.
And I will let you give a better
bio, but just really quickly,
so you guys are aware
of Marc's tenure
that he brings to the great
city of Detroit, he spent--
I know you opened
20 restaurants.
I don't know-- or
eight restaurants
over 20 years with
Wolfgang Puck, right?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yes,
you are correct.
SPEAKER: Correct.
MARC DJOZLIJA: I grew up in
Madison Heights, Michigan.
And I graduated from
Lamphere High School.
SPEAKER: Wahoo!
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yep.
And--
SPEAKER: Any Lamphere
grads in the room?
That's right next to
my house, but anyway.
MARC DJOZLIJA: That's OK.
That's OK.
SPEAKER: OK.
Yep.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And I left pretty
much right after I was 18.
And I started bouncing
around the country.
I went to cooking
school in New York.
And I went to Maui, Hawaii.
I went to Las Vegas.
That's where I met Wolfgang.
I went to Los Angeles.
And then, I went
back to Las Vegas.
to Atlantic City.
And when I was in
Atlantic City, he said,
you know, Marc, we're going to
open a restaurant in Detroit.
I'll do my Wolfgang--
you know, Marc,
we open a restaurant
in Detroit, Michigan.
You go back to your hometown.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: That's a good one.
That's really--
[LAUGHING]
MARC DJOZLIJA: You know,
I'll tell you a funny story.
Well, I was at a
dinner one time.
And Wolfgang was there.
They go, hey, Marc, you
should know Wolfgang.
Marc does a great
impression of you.
I go, that's really a way to
get the good side of Wolfgang,
you know what I mean?
I'm making fun of
him on my free time.
So he said, you go back
to Detroit, Michigan.
He goes, you want to
go back to Detroit?
And we opened a restaurant.
I said, Detroit, like
Detroit, Michigan?
You know, it's 2005.
I said, have you been?
He said, it's going
to be in the casino.
It will be fine.
We'll get some good commerce.
So I came back
with the intention
of opening the first
restaurant at the MGM
Grand, when the MGM opened.
And I said, the only stipulation
I have is I want my next gig.
I wouldn't plan on
staying here for 10 years.
I'd do it for a couple of years.
I'd move on to the
next opportunity.
And he was going to
go back to Hawaii
to run all the food and beverage
at a small hotel on Waikiki
Beach.
2009 comes around.
The economy goes bad.
And all of our deals dried up.
So there was nowhere to go.
So I stayed on for a
couple of more years.
And then, the lease
agreement was going to end.
And the MGM wanted
the facility back,
because we were the
only restaurant that
wasn't on the casino floor.
And someone under
the age of 18 or 21
could come to the restaurant.
So they want to make it a
more casual restaurant, which
is now TAP, the sports bar.
So the deal was we would take
over the other two restaurants.
They were [INAUDIBLE]
restaurants at the time.
So I opened both
of those, as well.
SPEAKER: Oh, OK.
MARC DJOZLIJA:
But in the hiatus,
shall we say, when I was
considering whether or not
I still wanted to
stay in Detroit
and how this was
going to work out,
I lived right downtown Detroit.
And I moved back in 2007.
So when I moved back, I said
there's only 50 people that
live downtown.
I know, because everywhere I
go, I see the same 50 people.
[LAUGHING]
Living on Woodward, I also
had to walk out my front door,
and I said, where do I get to
go eat and drink in this town,
you know what I mean?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MARC DJOZLIJA: You know, there
were some places, Detroit Beer
Company, Vicente's,
so on, and so forth.
But when the town
started to change,
with a lot of new
commerce that came,
I would walk out my
front door and I'd
see lots of young
professionals, like yourself.
I said, where do they
get to go eat and drink?
SPEAKER: Right.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And that's when
the whole mindset changed.
I said, I think we
should try and do
something downtown in
the core of the city,
trying to create what
we call, The Gathering
Place, the kind of place
where you could come
for a beer before
the baseball game,
a glass of wine after the opera
house, or anything in between.
Make it approachable,
reasonably priced,
and hopefully, with not much
to compare it to at that time,
we thought that would be
our core business model.
And we were very fortunate
the way it worked out.
SPEAKER: And if you
didn't hear earlier,
we were saying a group of us
actually went to Wright and Co.
last night just to check
out the scene and not--
four out of the five of us
had never been there before.
So we spent some
time looking for it.
We were expecting-- you said
it was on Woodward Avenue.
We were on the first floor
across from the Aloft Hotel,
knew it was by John
Varvatos, and then, the one
person in our group
who had been said, oh,
it's on the second floor.
So the first question
I had for Marc,
and I'd love for you to talk
about that with the group,
too, was, why did you
choose loft space?
That's so interesting and
it's such a new concept
for what the
American small plates
atmosphere is that you provide.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Well--
SPEAKER: So it's an
interesting story.
Also make sure you tell the
John Varvatos story, too,
because I love that.
MARC DJOZLIJA: I will.
[CHUCKLING]
So I knew Richard
[? Shiad, ?] who
was the legal counsel
for then Dan Gilbert.
He used to come in the original
Wolfgang Puck restaurant.
His wife, they'd
always come in late
because he would
get off work late.
And then, when I would finish
work, he'd say, oh, sit down.
Have a glass of wine with me
and let's talk about Detroit.
Bedrock and Quicken
Loans and the whole group
is trying to figure out
what Detroit needed,
and talk to the people
that lived downtown,
and say, what do you miss?
What do you think we should
be doing, so on and so forth.
So when I started to look for
something, I called Richard.
And I said, can you
find someone who
can show me around some
of your vacant buildings
and see if we can
engage in a concept?
The original space that I
liked, the next meeting,
I bought my business partner,
Dave Kwiatkowski, with me.
And I said, this is a space.
And the gentleman
who was there, he
goes, oh, no, you
can't have this space.
It's already been leased.
And you got some
bad information.
So they said, let us show
you some other spaces.
And none of them really worked.
And they said, we
have one last space
we haven't showed anybody, yet.
And they took us up to Wright
& Company on the second floor.
And it was all beat
up wood, and the light
was shining through the windows.
It looked very European
coffee shop-ish.
And we fell in
love with the space
before we knew we what we
were going to do with it.
Dave's like, this is perfect.
So we're all excited.
And then, the next day,
we're like, perfect for what?
[LAUGHING]
What are we going to do with it?
You know what I mean?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So people, we--
I let me retract.
Me, Dave consider ourselves
good eaters, drinkers,
and travelers.
And we wanted to create
the kind of place
that we would seek out if
we went to another city.
So if you go to a place
like Washington, DC,
or Philadelphia,
or New York City,
there's lots of places
on second floors,
lots of places in
basements, lots
of places in alleys,
which we have one of those
now, as well, a
cocktail bar called,
The Bad Luck, which
we can get to later.
But we did it--
we did what we thought was cool.
We tried to create
the kind of place
that we wanted to
hang out all day.
And then, we kind
of hope that just
resonated with everybody else.
And we didn't think we
needed a ton of people
to gather the
concept, just enough.
So we did it and just hoped
that it all worked out.
Now, the first three days
we opened, nobody came.
And we thought it was
the worst idea we ever
came up with in our whole life.
[LAUGHING]
And then, the next day,
it started to trickle in,
trickled in.
And people found it.
And then, there's some
buzz that got created.
And then, everything's been
fantastic ever since then.
So John-- so we were
in the [? industry ?]
of the restaurant.
And Bedrock had been
talking about the retail
that they were trying
to create around us
to stimulate some business
on the Woodward corridor.
And they said John
Varvatos is one
of the gentleman that's
looking to come to Detroit
and open a store.
So we were interested
to hear that someone
like that was coming.
So it was early in the
morning, me and Dave
where the only ones
in the restaurant.
And the elevator opened
up, and the elevator
dings when the door opens up.
And 10 young people come in,
10 young men dressed really
sharply, skinny
kids, good looking.
SPEAKER: Skinny kids.
[LAUGHING]
MARC DJOZLIJA: I'm like,
well, who let them get here?
Because the elevator is locked.
And so they come--
SPEAKER: They're starving.
They're skinny kids.
MARC DJOZLIJA: They kind of
panned out through the room,
and then opened up,
and then, Dan Mullen,
who was the representative
for Bedrock,
Jim Ketai, Dan's business
partner, and John Varvatos
walk in behind them.
So we get up, and Dan
Mullen says, this is Mark,
and this is Dave, and
they own Wright & Company.
And John Varvatos
is looking around.
He's like, you two
own this place?
We say, yes, we do.
Yes.
He said, a pretty badass space.
And I said, well, coming
from a gentleman like you--
I go, that's one
heck of a compliment.
[LAUGHING]
And so he said, I'm thinking
about inhabiting downstairs.
How do you feel about that?
I said, only if we get to
throw your grand opening party.
And so, I had heard when
he took over the old punk
bar in New York City and
opened a clothing store,
he left the stage in and KISS
played the grand opening party.
So I knew it was going
to be a big affair.
So Alice Cooper
played in the store.
And we were the
VIP room upstairs.
SPEAKER: So awesome.
MARC DJOZLIJA: They
blocked off Woodward,
and about 600 people came.
SPEAKER: Wow.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah,
so only so many people
could come upstairs.
But I didn't tell
you this story.
So the VIPs got to go to
the balcony at what the John
Varvatos store is and watch the
Alice Cooper show, and then, go
back up.
And Dave comes down and he
says, the fire marshals here
and he's really upset with us.
There's too many people
in Wright & Company.
And I said, well, there
was security, supposed
to check their wristbands.
Why isn't he
checking wristbands?
I don't know, but
the place is a zoo.
So I watched the
end of the show.
I go back upstairs.
And there's a security guard.
And he goes, where's
your wristband?
SPEAKER: To you?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah.
[LAUGHING]
And I said, rumor has it you
should have been asking that
about an hour ago because,
apparently there's too many.
So I gave him my card.
He lets me in.
And literally, it was like
wall to wall of people.
SPEAKER: Oh, my gosh.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So we had
to get some people out.
We had tables set up for Dan
Gilbert and for Alice Cooper.
And Michael Bolton was
there and some other people,
so we had to make sure
everybody got taken care of.
But it's kind of funny
they wouldn't even
let me back in my own
restaurant after I
decided to throw the party.
SPEAKER: So does that present
logistical challenges then,
being on the second floor
with coolers or storage or--
MARC DJOZLIJA: It does.
And you know, I will talk about
the view here in a second.
But yeah, all of our
storage is downstairs.
So all our walk-in coolers,
all our dry storage,
our Fort Knox of booze
is all in the basement.
So every day, the situation
is that prep people
prep whatever's
on the list, take
it downstairs, rotate the
stock, bring the stock upstairs,
stock the restaurant
for service,
and then when they
leave, the cooks come in
and the place should
be set up for them.
So you had mentioned,
why don't we do lunch?
That's part of the reason.
I don't know what to
do with a staff who
is spending all day
right now setting up
so we can have a busy dinner.
Like Katy Perry's
at the LCA tonight,
so we're planning to
have a pretty big night
and some good commerce downtown.
So you had also
mentioned originally
about the second floor.
You know, if you're
on the first floor
of a building in a storefront,
you see cars and people.
On the second floor, if you
look out Wright Company,
or if you're in
table 40-- we call
it the VIP table it's the
one that was next to you,
with the turret.
SPEAKER: I wasn't at the
VIP table last night?
MARC DJOZLIJA: No, you weren't.
You're right.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Oh, I thought I was.
MARC DJOZLIJA: You weren't
there till after dinner.
You know, you've got to
let me know ahead of time,
so I reserve it for you.
But you can look right down
Woodward, all the way to Campus
Martius and see the cityscapes.
SPEAKER: Yeah, it's beautiful.
MARC DJOZLIJA:
You see cityscape.
You see architecture.
You see more than just
people walking around.
And it's a totally
different dynamic.
And that's what we really
fell in love with, as well.
SPEAKER: The restaurant
was completely illuminated
last night, too, because
of all the holiday lights.
You could see the tree
from Campus Martius.
And it's just so beautiful
what that stretch of Woodward
has become.
And with the Shinola Hotel
going up a couple doors
away from you, you made
the right decision.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Well, they said
all the commerce around us,
the Element Hotel will be right
behind us, the Siren Hotel,
will be right next to them.
So when we talked about
timing and location,
it just worked out
amazing for us.
But at the time, we
totally speculated
that, if we were
close to the arenas
and we were close to the
event spaces, that maybe
we could draw some
traffic to the area.
And no matter how
quirky the space was--
but like I said, it
get's better every day.
And now, the LCA has
really helped us, as well,
because of the fact that, when
you talk about 20,000 people
coming down on a
Wednesday in wintertime,
you know that, if
1% of them comes
to Wright and
Company, 200 people,
that's incrementally
going to be a much better
Wednesday than we
would normally have.
So five events a week between
the Pistons, the Red Wings,
and all the concerts, so that
also helps for us, as well.
So like I said, every
time you read an article,
you're like, is--
we seem to be in the
general vicinity of what's
going on in some
capacity, which is great.
SPEAKER: Well, and
it does bring down
a more diverse and unique
crowd than the sports
crowds that you get at
Ford Field or at the CoPa,
so that'll be good
for you guys, too.
And then, us, of course,
when we move down to Detroit.
We'll all come down.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And we look
forward to that, as well.
So we also have another venue.
We have a Chinese
restaurant in what
was the old Chinatown,
called The Peterboro.
So I don't know if you're
familiar with that.
It is on the other side of
LCA, so it's about one mile,
catty-corner.
It's right behind
the Masonic Temple
in what was the old Chinatown.
So the building right
across the street from us,
Chung's, was the last
Chinese restaurant
that was still open in
the old Chinatown in 2000.
And a gentlemen we partnered
with found this facility,
wanted to rehab the
building, and thought
it'd be cool to open
a Chinese restaurant
in the old Chinatown.
So we opened a place called The
Peterboro about two years ago.
And so we also have that
on the other side of us
that also is perfectly
located for the new arena.
And Founders Brewery just opened
across the street from us,
now, which will also
bring people to the area.
We're bridging the
gap between the arena
and what is quote,
unquote, "Midtown,"
on the other side of
Martin Luther King,
where it was kind of
the Cass corridor.
But the shipping
container facility,
you may have read about,
the Detroit shipyard
is right next to us.
So that's being built, as well.
So we're going to be
right smack, hopefully,
again in an emerging
area of Detroit,
where all the commerce
will come up around us.
And we will just hopefully
position ourself properly,
again.
SPEAKER: It's such
an exciting time.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And
we do have a cocktail
bar called The Bad Luck that's
in an alley in The Albert.
SPEAKER: Is this
the super secret
project you were working
on for a Fall 2017 opening
that you couldn't comment on?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: OK, tell us about it.
That's exciting.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So
if you've ever been
downtown to the Belt, where
like Standby is and the Skip,
that's an alley, very, very
nice decorated, graffiti--
we're in a functioning
alley, like real alley,
like, bums, dumpster alley.
SPEAKER: OK.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And it
wasn't really purposeful,
like we didn't want to create
some experience like it's
going to be an
adventure to get there,
but it was a space
that became available.
They didn't know
what to do with it.
It was a really good deal.
SPEAKER: Yeah, I bet.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So we created--
and we also wanted to create
something a little more grown
up, shall we say.
You know, I have no--
first of all, I know
everybody downtown.
So if I say anybody's name,
I say it with affection.
I love Standby.
I love what it is.
But sometimes, it's a
little more like a club.
SPEAKER: Right.
MARC DJOZLIJA: We
wanted somewhere
where you could sit across from
your date, have a nice drink,
and a sedate atmosphere,
a little more grown up,
shall we say, so we created
this cocktail bar called The Bad
Luck.
And it's based on
the tarot cards.
Our 13 seasonal drinks were
all based on the tarot cards.
SPEAKER: Well, that's neat.
MARC DJOZLIJA: It's
a call-ahead program.
You call up, and they tell
you how long before your table
will be ready.
That way, you don't walk down
this alley in your high heels,
or you're in the snow, or
whatever it turns out to be.
And then, when you get in,
it's a secret little oasis
in this alley to where we have
a really sexy cocktail bar.
There is no food.
If you're hungry, Wright &
Company's a block that way.
[LAUGHING]
So we'll help you out that way.
We'll get you a reservation.
SPEAKER: Would you
call it a speakeasy?
MARC DJOZLIJA: We don't, per se.
I mean, I think that term
gets a little overused.
We just have a really
sexy cocktail bar.
And we're proud that we
were recognized by "Eater"
by-- they had the
design awards this year.
We were the best designed place.
So we just got that the
other day, which is cool.
So people are recognizing
for what it is.
SPEAKER: We had a long
day at our client's office
yesterday before we came
into the restaurant.
And it was funny.
We told one of our
clients in the meeting
where we were eating dinner at.
And she goes, oh, my
god, the food is amazing.
But honestly, the best part
is Jake, the bartender.
He's so hot.
[LAUGHING]
So you can have Jake at
the Bad Luck Bar, maybe.
Maybe you should consider that.
[LAUGHING]
MARC DJOZLIJA: Hey, listen,
every little bit helps.
I told you last time--
SPEAKER: Whatever it takes.
MARC DJOZLIJA: --we
only have a couple
of rules at Wright & Company.
The first one is, we hope
you have a good time,
enjoy your meal, and you
tell your friends, right?
And the other one is, you hope
your credit card goes through.
Besides that, you
know what I mean?
[LAUGHING]
Everything else is
up for discussion.
So if you come to see Jake,
I'm cool, you know what I mean?
I'm cool.
SPEAKER: OK, all right.
Yeah.
MARC DJOZLIJA: That's
the draw this week.
SPEAKER: I'm sad I didn't
get to meet him last night,
but we'll come back.
So at The Bad Luck, then--
well, can you read--
do you read tarot cards
or is it just you designed
based off the 13 tarot cards?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yani Frye
is our managing partner.
He used to work and be the head
bartender at The Sugar House.
So he's there.
He devises all the drinks.
And so the 13 tarot card drinks
are just like anything else.
You can have whatever you want.
If you want to gin
and tonic, if you
want something else to drink,
he's happy to make it for you.
But we're trying to
promote what we would do.
And you know, we got a little
bit of flak, shall we say,
when we first opened up.
We did have a $90 cocktail.
It was based on a--
SPEAKER: Wow.
MARC DJOZLIJA: --flagon
of [INAUDIBLE] rum
from the British Navy from 1957.
And so--
SPEAKER: I want that.
MARC DJOZLIJA: --we would pour
it for you one ounce neat,
so you could try it on its own,
and one ounce in the daiquiri.
So you technically
got two drinks.
And so there was a lot
of talk about the $90,
but realistically, if you go
to any bar worth its weight,
they may have some
Pappy Van Winkle,
which may cost you $120.
They may have Louis
the XIII, the cognac,
that may cost you $150.
So we didn't really
understand why the--
like, we were trying
to outplay everybody
with our $90 cocktail
wasn't really the premise.
We just said, we have
something very unique.
And you're not
going to get this.
So we got all three
flagons of this.
So we monopolized
the rum aspect of it.
So if you want to have it,
you've got to come see us.
SPEAKER: You still have it?
You didn't get rid of it just
because you had flak, right?
MARC DJOZLIJA: No, no, no.
SPEAKER: OK, good.
Good.
MARC DJOZLIJA: No,
no, it's still there.
But I'm just saying,
there was a little flak
about what we were
trying to create.
And that was not the intention.
But as they say, no publicity
is bad publicity sometimes.
SPEAKER: That's true.
Yeah, that's true.
Well, so I want to talk a
little bit more about you.
MARC DJOZLIJA: OK.
SPEAKER: And one of the things
I read about you that I thought
was really interesting
was, someone
as talented as you are in
the culinary space usually
comes out of the womb screaming,
this is what I want to do.
But you didn't really get that
bug until much later in life,
even though you graduated
from the Culinary Institute
Arts of America.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So
you are correct.
SPEAKER: So tell us about that.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So I was not the
best student in high school.
And so when my parents
were starting to press me,
like what are you going
to be when you grow up,
the only thing I was
really good at was math.
So I didn't really foresee
myself to be an accountant
or anything like that.
So I had a couple of buddies.
There was a vocational
school that you
could go to instead of
taking your elective credits
in high school.
SPEAKER: OK.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So
during the day,
you would take the
things you had to,
like government or English.
And then, in the afternoon, you
go to this vocational school,
and you could learn a trade.
So one of them was taking
auto mechanics, where
he worked on his car all day.
And the other one was
taking heating and cooling.
And there was cosmetology
and other things like that.
And there was food service.
So me being the-- trying
to get out of school,
as opposed to engage
more in school,
I said, this is a great idea.
I think I'll take food service.
I thought, if nothing else,
maybe I'll make some food
that I could eat.
That's why I'm fat.
[LAUGHING]
And then, maybe, I'll meet some
girls, you know what I mean?
So that was my whole
premise, right?
SPEAKER: Yeah, in
cooking class, yeah.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And so
after doing it for a while,
it turned out I was
really good at it.
Recipes were easy to decipher,
measurements, and the tech.
I like to work on my hands, so
that all kind of came together.
So my teacher would
start having me
help with someone who
was struggling, because I
would be a little faster.
She said, will you help Laura
out with the cake or whatever?
So I kind of said,
well, maybe this is it.
Maybe this is what we should do.
And a gentleman came from the
Culinary Institute of America
and said--
and told us about the
school for about 45 minutes,
and then handed
out applications,
told us how it works.
And so I went home
to my mom and dad.
I said-- and this is
in late '80s, mind you.
It wasn't exactly
that fashionable to be
a chef or that cool.
There was no Food Network
or things like that.
[LAUGHING]
So I went home
and I said, I want
to go to this cooking
school in New York.
My dad said, this
is a joke, right?
Like, you want to go
cook for a living?
My dad was a prominent engineer
working for General Motors,
things like that.
So I said, I don't
know what else you
want from me because I don't
know how to do anything else.
And I feel good like this.
So I'm going to try.
So they said, OK.
They didn't believe me.
I'd pay.
So I had to pay
for my first half.
So I get some jobs
when I was in school.
And once I started
to excel, they
paid for the rest of
my schooling and said,
this is going to work out.
So sometimes, you just kind
of fall into some things.
And then I started bouncing
around the country.
And once I went
to Maui, Hawaii, I
didn't take it that
seriously, either.
I was on the beach.
SPEAKER: I feel like you're
not supposed to, though.
I mean, you're in Waikiki.
You're not supposed to.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah, so I
was fooling around in Maui.
I worked for a restaurant.
I learned some things.
And I felt like I had to
get more focused on it
if I was going to.
So I got a job at the
Hilton Corporation.
And then, they transferred
me to Las Vegas,
where my parents were,
which I thought was
going to be a good opportunity.
And I then I met
Wolfgang Puck when
he opened in 1993,
when he opened
the restaurant in Las Vegas.
And so, then the rest,
shall we say, is history.
Because the timing was good.
And I met the right
man at the right time,
who helped you
become a better chef.
I used to make Wolfgang
dishes, and he'd be like,
you're going about
this all wrong.
You're trying to
create something
that doesn't have the proper
flavor profiles or any of that.
And I talk to young chefs,
now, about this all the time.
He said, start with
something you like.
Start with something
you know that works.
So he says, take ham and
cheese, for instance.
Everybody likes a ham and
cheese sandwich, right?
SPEAKER: Everybody.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And
if you do, maybe you
like mustard on it, right?
So you know the flavor profiles
work-- ham, cheese, mustard.
So you can, in turn,
create anything
with those flavor profiles that
could be cool or different.
And I look back at a dish we're
doing right now on our menu,
which is a gnocchi.
It's a Parisian gnocchi.
So it's crispy,
but it's Parmesan
and a Parmesan broth with
prosciutto, which is there.
And then your bread
is the gnocchi.
So it's like, in a way, you
use the bread is a gnocchi,
the Parmesan and the
Parmesan broth is the cheese,
and the prosciutto is the ham.
So I didn't even
do that on purpose.
Sometimes it comes
self-consciously.
But you can look back
at different aspects
and say, see how
that worked together?
And the things that he
taught you and how to do that
are things that still
apply to what I do today
and the style that I try
and create through our food.
SPEAKER: It's so basic.
And yet-- I have to read this.
The pork belly sliders
that you brought,
tomato jam, arugula, sriracha
aioli on a toasted brioche bun.
And it's the best
thing I have ever had.
It's so amazing.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Just like with--
if I talk about
cocktails, as well,
there's just a start
and end of every food.
So you eat something, and
if you don't have the start
or you don't have
the end, then there's
something missing, whether it's
acid or something to bring it
up or salt to elevate a flavor.
There's something
that's missing.
And that bite is
perfect because you
have the butteriness
of the brioche bun,
the bitterness of the arugula,
the sweetness of the tomato
jam, the spiciness of sriracha,
and the smokiness of the pork
belly.
So you have you covered
a gamut of flavors.
So when you eat
it, a lot happens.
But also back to Wolfgang,
the sriracha aioli
is three ingredients.
The tomato jam is
five ingredients.
It's tomatoes, it's apples,
it's lemon juice, it's sugar.
That's four ingredients.
So one's got to take
several simple ideas
to create one complex idea
is the game, shall we say.
Find the best
products you can find,
handle them properly, and
then, create the flavor profile
so that it works.
So I could teach you how to make
that dish, but you have to--
no, seriously, because they
said I have [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER: Thank you.
MARC DJOZLIJA: But they said you
have to understand the flavor
profiles to get to that point.
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Trial and
error, sounds like a good idea.
There's lots of
things we've made
that we thought were a good
idea that we were like,
that's a terrible idea.
And they never made the menu.
SPEAKER: And speaking
about ingredients,
and keeping it local,
and Detroit coming up,
do you have a lot of-- do you
source a lot of the ingredients
that you make in the
restaurant from local places?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yes,
as much as possible.
Now, the urban
farming scene isn't
growing as fast as we'd like.
So sometimes, you want
10 pounds of green beans
and they have five
pounds of green beans.
Because you want green beans.
I want green beans.
He wants green beans.
We all want the same
products, you know?
People like Recovery
Park and people
like that are doing a
really great job with it.
You can't grow fast enough
for busy restaurants.
I mean, some of the places
like Chartreuse and Selden
Standard and us, we're busy.
So we're using a lot of carrots.
We're not using a
bunch of carrots.
We're using boxes of carrots.
So we do as much
as we can, and then
you just have to
supplement, accordingly.
And the new facet really is
now that different people are
trying to grow stuff for you.
So right now, people
engage and say,
tell us what you
think you're going
to need in the summertime, even
if it's a pedestrian product
like a cucumber.
If you know you're going to need
it, we'll have a plot of land,
we'll grow cucumbers
twice, and we'll
harvest on one while the
other ones are growing,
then harvest back and forth,
back and forth, back and forth,
and maybe keep you in
cucumbers all summer.
So people are looking at
more interesting techniques
to try and get the
products to us, as well.
SPEAKER: So are
these local sellers
who approach you sort of cold
call-ish in the restaurant?
MARC DJOZLIJA: A
lot of them who are.
There's people in 7 Mile
and Woodward, and Bernard
Parks, who does some things at
the old school over off Monroe,
and, obviously, Recovery
Park and people like that.
A lot of local people
that come and say here's--
they send you lists really
what's going to be available.
Here's what we have now.
Here's what we have in a
couple of weeks from now.
And here's what we'll
have moving forward.
So you try and get in
before everybody else.
SPEAKER: Yeah, definitely.
MARC DJOZLIJA: I don't
know if it works this way,
but you try to be the
first one to email,
like, I'll take the green beans.
And hope I said yes before
Andy said yes or something
like that.
But they're all really
good friends of mine.
So we like to--
everybody wants
to have something
that they can showcase, as well.
SPEAKER: So you're
still, though-- you're
saying that there's an
opportunity for urban farming,
too, in downtown Detroit.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Oh,
no, no, absolutely.
SPEAKER: If anyone's a farmer.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Well, the
only thing I will say is--
SPEAKER: 20% projects.
MARC DJOZLIJA: I can't
say how lucrative it is.
I don't know the work
versus profit margin
to come out of it is, I mean,
a lot of our passion projects,
things like that.
But yeah, there's lots of room
for lots of things in Detroit,
contrary to popular opinion.
SPEAKER: We just heard
about one new project.
Do you have your eye
on anything else?
MARC DJOZLIJA: We always do.
SPEAKER: Future?
MARC DJOZLIJA:
We're engaged a lot.
But the town has
changed, as well.
I mean, real estate
is more expensive.
Contracting is more expensive.
I mean, if we were talking--
if I was trying to build
Wright & Company today,
3 and 1/2 years
later, it'd probably
cost me 30% to 40%
more than it did.
SPEAKER: Yeah, wow.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Because
they said, well,
the demand for contractors--
and just like we talked
about, people of the industry
having trouble filling
some of these jobs.
Same thing with contractors.
The LCA took up a lot of people.
So a lot of projects
got put on hold
because they use
as many resources
they could to get that open.
And now, a lot of
the residential
that's happening in
Brush Park is taking up
a lot of contractors.
The guys that are going to build
your floor or the woodworkers
are all building cabinets
for different projects, now.
And so the price escalates,
material escalates.
And the way we desire to engage,
as far as tenant improvement
plans, money that we
expect the people who
own the buildings
to invest, as well,
doesn't always jive
with everybody, either.
So we talk more than we engage,
but we have an opportunity
possibly on the table that
we think might work out
in the springtime.
SPEAKER: Hopefully in the LCA?
In?
MARC DJOZLIJA: If
it was that easy.
[LAUGHING]
If it was that easy.
SPEAKER: We'll have to
have you to the new office
when it opens and maybe let you
come and do a guest chef day
or something.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Oh,
I'd be delighted to.
SPEAKER: OK, that'd be great.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Well, I know that we're
about 10 minutes out here.
And I don't know if anyone
has any questions for Marc.
But I want to make
sure I left some time.
I think you might have to use
the microphone because we're
filming.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Chef.
I've been to Wright & Co. a
couple times and I love it--
MARC DJOZLIJA: Well, thank you.
AUDIENCE: --by the way.
But I had a question about
the restaurant, actually.
Behind the bar, there
is a beautiful painting.
SPEAKER: Oh, yeah,
it's stunning.
AUDIENCE: And I want to-- it's
like a ship on stormy seas.
And I wanted to know,
is there a story?
I always wondered if there
there's a story behind that.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Well, there is.
So my business partner, Dave--
well, first of all,
the ceilings are
very high at Wright & Company.
So it's a very grandiose space.
And we didn't want to put
mirrors or something like that.
We were trying to
figure out what's
the focal point we could do.
So we bantered about
lots of different things.
And Dave had a smaller
replication of that painting.
It's by a very famous
maritime artist, Dutch--
[INAUDIBLE] Dutch,
Ludolf Bakhuizen.
And it's a replication
of a painting
from 1619 called "Ships
Running Aground in a Storm."
So Dave said it'd be cool if
we could have this focal point.
So we found a local
artist, Michelle Tanguay,
and we gave her the picture.
And we said, we'd like you
to replicate this for us.
And so she sent us pictures
every couple of weeks
as she was standing on a ladder,
trying to paint this thing.
And then, it was one
of the first things
we hung up because we didn't
want to have it damaged.
So before we put the banquettes
in, she tacked it on to plywood
on the floor.
And then we hung it on the wall.
And our woodworking guys
actually built the frame
around the outside of it.
And then we covered
in a tarp while we
did the rest of the work.
And actually, people talk about
the chandelier and the turrets.
Well, that was the
first thing we bought.
I bought it one week at an
auction at DuMouchelle's one
week after.
And it hung there for
about seven months.
They were very kind to leave
it there with a sold sign
because we didn't have
anything to do with it.
We didn't know-- we had to have
the ceiling done before we can
do the electrical and all
that, so it was no way to--
SPEAKER: The ceiling
is that beautiful--
I'm going to get this wrong,
but it's the tin that's the--
what do you call that,
the hammered tin?
Was is it?
You know it?
I don't know, but
it's so gorgeous.
MARC DJOZLIJA: So the ceiling is
a whole different, other story.
Again, there are some
really cool aspects
about the building.
If you're looking at the bar--
you're just looking at the
bar and to the left, there
a big piece of
plaster [INAUDIBLE]
that some hipster artwork.
That was where the
original elevator was.
The building was built
in 1891 by a gentleman
called Frederick Schwankovsky.
And he had the
Schwankovsky House of Music
was on the first floor.
And he inhabited it until 1920
until the great Kay Jewelers
inhabited the space.
And then, so downstairs
was an actual storefront
where you could buy jewelry.
And the second floor was
a private viewing room
where you go look at
all the fancy diamonds.
And at some point, they
turned it into a ballroom
and hosted parties there.
And that's where the name Wright
& Company came from, as well.
So we were trying to pay homage
to the history of the building,
itself.
So I said, what's the
name of the building?
They said Wright Kay.
And so why don't we call
it Wright & Company?
We're just a company that's
inhabiting this historic piece
of history in Detroit.
And then, in turn,
it became the House
of Fabrics and some other
things before it became dormant.
It was a couple of
nightclubs, and then it
turned out to be what it was.
But the ceiling--
so the first thing
we did after we cleaned
up the space is we
were going to blow out
the ceiling because we
wanted to have exposed rafters.
So we had to stain them, so it
didn't drip on everything else.
So we got some scaffolding,
and we took leaf blowers,
and we blew all the-- we
were blowing all the dust out
of this building had been
vacant for a long time.
And the guys upstairs
came downstairs
and they said, hey,
we need you to stop.
And so we thought we were
making too much noise.
And I said, are we bothering
you in some capacity?
They said, come on upstairs.
So we were blowing the
dust through the cracks
of the floor and
the little ant hills
and there was dust all
through that space.
So we apologized.
We sent a cleaning
crew in that weekend
and had them for two days.
They cleaned the
whole office building.
And then Monday
morning comes around,
and our representatives
from Bedrock said,
we need to talk
about the ceiling.
They said, we have some
sound issues, you know,
obviously this situation.
They said, what if we do this?
What if we insulate it,
[? firm ?] it with plywood.
We will pay for and
install any ceiling
of your choice, which sounded
very generous at the time.
But when we leave,
if we ever leave,
we're not taking
the ceiling with us
anyway, so will always be there.
So I was amenity
to their situation.
So we decided to have
something that would be shiny,
so when you came
down the street,
you could see the chandelier
and it speckles off the ceiling.
And then hopefully, you go,
what's going on up there,
to try and figure out how to get
in, have our own little game,
shall we say, or several
games we're trying to play.
And some of it more
purposeful than others.
We didn't desire to--
we didn't desire you to
enter through the alley
and have a real sign,
but to hang a sign
on a historic building
is very expensive.
You have to go through
a bunch of design work.
And so, at some point,
we just gave up.
It just became too
much of a chore.
So we have our little
sandwich board.
We wanted you to enter
through the alley, which
would be easier to hang
a sign because nobody
cares what you do in an alley.
But when they were working
on the Metropolitan,
some bricks fell off
on top of a truck
and we've had scaffolding
outside ever since.
It's been 3 and 1/2 years.
So we never really got it.
You can enter through the
alley, go up to the stairs,
but we never had
the entrance where
we were truly desired it because
of the construction around us.
So we'll see what
happens in the future.
But right now, I think,
for the most part,
people figure out
how to get there.
And then, you still see
people walking around--
I was telling her about
it-- with their phones.
[INAUDIBLE] out the window.
They go, I know it's
around here somewhere.
You know, they did it
last night [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER: That was us.
We were using the Google
Maps to try to find you.
But there is some--
there's some
cachet, if you will,
about finding the entrance
by the sandwich board.
That's literally the
only way, at least
that I could see last night,
to find Wright & Company.
And then, getting
up the elevator,
and then it kind of opens,
and you're like, wait, what?
It's a huge, beautiful space.
MARC DJOZLIJA: The
intrigue in the elevator,
and then, you come
around the corner,
and then you walk down
the little hallway,
and then the space opens up.
And hopefully, everybody
feels that way.
You know what I mean?
SPEAKER: I think so.
Yeah, you have a very special
thing going on down there.
MARC DJOZLIJA: When we
talked about the elevator,
I skipped over it.
It was one of the first
buildings in Detroit
to have an elevator.
So it was called the Elevator
Building, originally.
SPEAKER: Oh, it was?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah, so yeah.
And one other side note,
which is a cool story.
The lady-- the last opera--
I don't know why I'm drawing
a blank on what the last opera
was at the opera house--
the lead in the opera was
a great great granddaughter
of Frederick Schwankovsky.
SPEAKER: Oh, wow.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And so she
had never been to Detroit.
She had heard about the
building and the business.
And then they contacted
us from the opera house.
And we had a little party.
And anybody could of came.
And she actually saying
three songs in the space--
SPEAKER: Oh, that's cool.
MARC DJOZLIJA: --yeah, for--
SPEAKER: In the restaurant?
MARC DJOZLIJA: In
the restaurant.
SPEAKER: Where would
you have a singer?
MARC DJOZLIJA: We just--
she was just in the turret,
you know what I mean?
And she just told the
story about her great great
grandfather and him building
the building and the history
of her family, and
then her history
and how she got back to
Detroit for the opera.
And then she sang a few songs.
And then that was
pretty much it.
So it was cool that her--
SPEAKER: Did she
sing operatic or--
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER: Oh, wow.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah, so--
SPEAKER: Billowing throughout.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And all of
the family was invited.
So we saved some
places for them,
so they could watch her
sing and things like that.
So it's kind of cool to bring
some of the history back.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MARC DJOZLIJA: And
also, everybody
who's ever known the
Wright Kay building
has some story about it, or,
it was vacant for a long time,
so people used to live in there.
My father bought his
class ring downstairs.
God rest his soul.
SPEAKER: At Kay Jewelers?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yes.
God rest his soul, but yeah,
when he was in high school,
he bought his--
when I showed him, I told him
I was going to quit my job
and open my own restaurant.
And once again, the
second time he thought I
was even crazier to becoming
a chef in the first place.
[LAUGHING]
But I showed up the building.
And he goes, oh, my god, I
bought my class ring there--
SPEAKER: Aw.
MARC DJOZLIJA: --when
I was in high school.
So it was cool.
SPEAKER: That is the
cool thing about Detroit.
Everyone has some
kind of connection,
even in you live
up in the burbs--
[MUSIC SOUND EFFECT]
--or you haven't been here very
long, it's seems like that.
MARC DJOZLIJA: No, absolutely.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for coming in, Marc.
We appreciate it.
That's a good segue
into my question.
I was just wondering,
you've been in Detroit
for a long time with
some departures outside,
but born and raised here
and went to school here,
and have been very instrumental
in kind of the re-invigoration
of downtown.
What do you see--
10 years from now, what do
you see Detroit as being?
And what gets you excited for
what that might look like?
MARC DJOZLIJA: Well, as
much as I am from Detroit,
I also am a realist
and I see the flaws.
So I hope Dan Gilbert sees this.
Listen, Dan, I'm telling
you what you need to do.
[LAUGHING]
You know, when we first
engaged with them,
they were very purposeful about
the downtown and the Woodward
Corridor, and trying to create
unique shopping experiences.
When we first met
them, they said,
when we redeveloped
the Hudson's Site,
we'd like to have
a department store.
And I said, which department
store do you desire to have?
And they said, we'd like to
have Bloomingdale's, would
be our first choice.
And so this is five years ago.
I go, don't you think
Bloomingdale's is
a little highfalutin
for the area?
And they said, what
we're trying to do
is trying to say that there
is no-- the reason we'd
like Bloomingdale's
is because there are
none of the state of Michigan.
If you want to shop
at Bloomingdale's, you
have to come downtown to do it.
And so that was their
mindset as far as creating
retail of things you can't
get anywhere else, the reasons
to come downtown, to rebuild
the tax base, commerce,
so on, and so forth.
Hopefully, it all trickles down.
And maybe you want
to live there,
and then, restaurants
like ours, maybe you
want to live by
there, live downtown
because there's a cool place
to eat and drink and all this.
But what we do need
to do next is--
the QLine is fine.
But we need to create better
public transportation.
And we need to create
purposeful retail.
And I joked around
it the other day
like, where do I go buy
a pair of socks downtown?
You know what I mean?
I live right on the
Woodward Corridor,
but where do I go buy
the necessities of home
for downtown?
And if you're expecting the--
with the escalation
of residential,
which was also
escalating in price.
For anybody that knows
and lives downtown,
it's not cheap to live downtown.
And if you're expecting people
to have a car because all
of your retail is 10 miles that
way, that way, or that way,
pay the car insurance, and
not be able to get around
on public transportation,
then you've
got to start building things
where they don't need a car.
They don't need to pay that.
And they don't need the
public transportation.
Because I can take
the QLine to a Target,
or I can get to a
Meijer, or whatever you
desire, or a
Nordstrom Rack, so I
go buy a shirt to go
out on a Friday evening.
Those are the things that I have
to start filling in the gaps,
or the residential
will never truly
fill out, because
people will say,
I can live somewhere
else cheaper
where I can have all
the amenities I need.
They got it in, like, Ferndale.
And then we don't rebuild
the tax base is really
what this is all
about, getting people
to live, work, engage in
downtown in the wake of,
what, three years of
bankruptcy, only three
years out of bankruptcy.
And that's the other
crazy thing, too.
I was talking about this is
the elevator to somebody.
You know, Wright & Company's
only been open 3 and 1/2 years.
And although, we were
in the forefront,
we don't take really
any credit from that.
If Andy Hollyday hadn't
bought the building,
Selden Standard would have
been open before we would,
because they--
he quit his job a year
before I quit mine.
And we're really
good friends, too.
So that's why I know.
But they opened a
few months after us.
But all of this has really only
happened the last three years.
You know, you talk about all
the cool restaurants or bars
or shopping or reasons
to go downtown,
it's really all happened
the last few years.
And we get clouded by that.
It seems like it's
been a long time.
Like, you said, I've
been here a long time.
I probably have.
I'm a veteran.
I've been here a
whopping 10 years.
You know what I mean?
It's been such a short
time to actually--
to get all of this going.
So it's going to take more time.
But that's what I
really hope for.
I hope for, not only
for myself, selfishly,
but so that for people
that live downtown say,
I want to stay because
I can get everything
I need out my front door
at some particular point.
SPEAKER: That's a great point.
We'll make sure we
get this to Dan.
MARC DJOZLIJA: I'll
have to tell him.
[LAUGHING]
SPEAKER: Awesome.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Tell him, to be
able to get everything you need
is cool, too.
SPEAKER: Well, I couldn't--
I am down there every day.
And I didn't know
there's a Lululemon now
underneath where you live and a
Nike store and, obviously, John
Varvatos.
But whole stretch,
if you guys haven't
been down there
in the last month,
it's just even boomed even more.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yeah, there's
Under Armour, Warby Parker--
SPEAKER: Under Armour, too,
MARC DJOZLIJA: --Bonobos.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
MARC DJOZLIJA: There's some more
coming, you know what I mean?
So I'll let Bedrock do their
own press, so I don't tell.
[LAUGHING]
Let's talk about who they're
going to put into the space.
I'm just saying, you know.
Just because they
tell me, I shouldn't
be telling everybody else.
I'll let them do the
announcement when
the new place is going to come.
But they are going to fill
up the Woodward Corridor.
They have other people
that are engaging.
Some cool things are going
to do on the Hudson's
site in the next few
years after they--
now, that's going to be really
interesting to watch them build
a 61-story residential/
office building right smack
in the middle of Detroit.
It's not going to make parking
or getting down there any
easier, but it'll be really
interesting to watch.
SPEAKER: Well, all that
other stuff is great,
but Wright & Company
is phenomenal.
And really, we know that you
are early into the scene,
into the restaurant
scene, really even now,
but we appreciate
you having such a--
it's a luxurious experience,
from a culinary standpoint,
but it is such an super
casual and approachable
and friendly and
warm place to be.
So thank you for giving
us the opportunity
to have a restaurant
like that in our city.
MARC DJOZLIJA: I'll
say one more thing.
Well, that was the main goal,
as I told you last night.
The original menu only was--
everything was under $20.
We didn't want to feel like you
can only come on your birthday,
your anniversary,
Valentine's Day,
feel like you could
come on a regular basis.
And there's only one
dish that's eclipsed it,
just because we wanted a
better steak, and it's $22.
So we want you to
be able to feel
like you can come over there,
have a glass of wine, a bite
to eat before a game,
after the opera house,
anything in between
and not break the bank.
And I think that's a very
Detroit way of looking at it,
too.
SPEAKER: It is.
MARC DJOZLIJA: That
everybody can come and enjoy
Wright & Company, regardless
of how you're dressed,
where you're going, and
be able to enjoy it.
SPEAKER: Well, we hope
that's the Detroit
in 10 years from now.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Yes,
absolutely, absolutely.
SPEAKER: Excellent.
Well, thanks.
Let's give Marc a big
round of applause.
And thank you, again,
for being here.
MARC DJOZLIJA: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]